september 1944
southeast of japan uss finback steams
toward the crash site of an american
plane
10 miles away a young pilot drifts
towards the shores of a japanese island
from which enemy ships set out towards
him
the situation appears hopeless
until two american planes from his
squadron appear overhead
the avenger aircraft strafe the japanese
vessels
and they retreat to the protection of
the shore
but now low on fuel the american planes
must return to their carrier
the aviator is vulnerable and alone
again
to the south uss finn back approaches
the coordinates of the downed airmen
guided in by its air cover
at last a lookout spots a bright yellow
object in the vast pacific
[Music]
from the life raft after more than three
hours of fear and struggle
the twenty-year-old pilot believes he
has started to hallucinate
as he sees what he describes as an
apparition
first a dark spot
then a submarine emerges
he worries it might be japanese
but he identifies the men on board with
relief
they are american
uss finback's photographic officer rolls
his camera
five submariners gather at finback's bow
to recover the bobbing life raft
[Music]
just before noon more than three hours
after the crash
they pulled the young pilot aboard
[Music]
he is safe
[Music]
you